l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée du projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération et à la simplification de
la rénovation de l'habitat dégradé et
des grandes opérations
d'aménagement la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des
[Applaudissements]
territoires
madame la Présidente Monsieur président
casbarian messieurs les rapporteurs Roy
Pérou et V mesdames et messieurs les
députés la République française ne SA ne
saurait tolérer qu'un seul de ses
enfants soit
plongé dans la situation d'indignité qui
consiste à vivre dans un habitat
précaire face à
l'indignité la seule réponse c'est
l'indignation et l'indignation quand on
est un responsable politique ça n'est
pas parler c'est agir
l'indignation c'est le discours puissant
du président de la République en
Marseille de à Marseille en juin 2023
qui qui s'est saisit à bras le corp du
sujet l'action mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est le travail mené depuis
plusieurs mois sous l'autorité
d'éliisabeth borne et par les ministres
du logement qu'on travaillaiit à mes
côtés que je veux saluer Olivier clin
qui a posé les bases de ce texte et
Patrice vercrit qui en a écrit
l'essentiel c'est aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle avec ce projet de loi
important qui vise à proposer des
solutions concrètes à un problème qui
touche la France entière et qui crée des
situations de détresse humaine que nous
ne sauion tolérer ce texte c'est donc à
la fois une promesse sociale et une
promesse
humaine qui intervient dans un contexte
où l'ensemble du secteur du logement est
plongé dans une crise profonde
multifactorielle à la fois
conjoncturelle et structurelle et à
laquelle nous nous efforçons de répondre
avec plusieurs ambitions complémentaires
au service de nos
concitoyens une ambition économique une
ambition écologique et une ambition
sociale ambition économique d'abord en
faisant en sorte que chacun puisse
acheter ou louer un logement
correspondant à ses besoins pour cela ce
sont les mesures immédiates de soutien à
la production de logement abordabl les
110000 nouveaux logements sociaux visés
en 2024 au travers de la mobilisation
renforcée du secteur HLM les 6 millions
de Français supplémentaires qui seront
éligibles au prêt àau zéro grâce au
nouveaux critères et au recentrage du
dispositif sur la production d've en
zone tendue une ambition écologique
ensuite par l'accélération de
l'adaptation du parc national de
logement aux enjeux de la transition
écologique et pour cela le gouvernement
investit massivement et j'insiste sur ce
terme massivement en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique et de la
décarbonation des
bâtiments cette politique je peux la
synthétiser à travers trois piliers la
lutte contre les passeoirs thermiques la
montée en puissance continue de ma prime
renove et l'effort de financement de la
rénovation du parc social enfin une
ambition sociale qui va être au cœur de
nos débats ces dimensions sont multiples
elles vont de l'hébergement d'urgence
pour lequel nous maintenons en 2024 un
niveau historiquement élevé de 203000
places disponibles avant les 120
millions d'euros qui commencent à se
déployer l'accélération de la
construction de logements sociaux bien
entendu et une dimension urgente qui
plus que les autres va nous occuper
aujourd'hui la lutte contre l'habitat
indigne et la requalification des
copropriétés
dégradé de quoi parlons-nous de ces
copropriétés dégradées dans le sens où
elles sont fragilisées par des problèmes
financiers ou des problèmes techniques
et qu'ell rencontent des difficultés
pour maintenir leurs immeubles en bon
état
aujourd'hui ce sont plus de 114000
copropriétés soit près de 1,5 million de
logement qui sont fragiles et qui
nécessiteront à court ou moyen terme une
intervention de la puissance publique
lorsque ces situations dégénère
lorsqu'oninvient pas lorsqu'on
intervient peu lorsqu'on intervient mal
cela peut menacer la santé et la
sécurité des occupants et conduire à des
drames aujourd'hui ce sont encore 400000
logements potentiellement indignes
occupés par un million de personnes dont
50 % de locataire une part conséquente
de ces logements sont en quartier
prioritaire de la ville et je comprends
ces élus locaux ou ses voisins de bonne
foi qui se sentent terriblement
impuissants face à des situations
dramatiques je les comprends et je sais
d'autant plus de quoi il parle qu'avant
d'avoir l'honneur de m'exprimer devant
vous à cette tribune j'ai été pendant
près de 10 ans maire d'une ville qui
compte SEP quartiers politiques de la
ville aujourd'hui enfin la longueur des
processus administratif semble
particulièrement inadapté aux
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer ses
copropriétés je vous livre ce chiffre
qui je crois est
frappant le
délai que vous devez compter pour les
dispositifs de redressement des
copropriétés en difficulté et de 5 à 10
ans c'est même jusqu'à 20 ans pour la
transformation des grands ensemble de
copropriétés confronté à des
dysfonctionnements majeurs au sein d'un
quartier ou pour la requalification de
quartiers ancien
dégradés quand on est dans l'urgence 5
ans 10 ans et je ne parle même pas de 20
ans c'était évidemment beaucoup trop
long pour répondre à ce constat le
gouvernement a déjà mis en œuvre un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui ont
fait leurs preuve et qui nous
encourageent à accélérer en 2018 c'était
le plan initiative copropriété 2,7
milliards d'euros d'intervention
publique sur 10 ans de manière à
accompagner à la fois les propriétés les
plus à risque et à traiter l'équivalent
de 88000
logement je pense également à la
simplification de la police de l'habitat
indigne à travers une ordonnance de 2020
permise par la loi hlan qui avait déjà à
l'époque été fermement soutenu par le
rapporteur
V cette réforme porte déjà ses fruits
puisque de 2018 à 2022 le nombre
d'arrêtés d'insalubrité a progressé de
30 % passant de 2700 à
3600 ce projet de loi n'est donc pas un
point de départ il marque une continuité
il a vocation à nous donner des outils
supplémentaires pour répondre à la crise
du logement que j'évoqué il s'inscrit
également dans la continuité des travaux
sur l'habitat indigne menés par la maire
de mulouse Michel Lutz et par le maire
de Saint-Denis Mathieu anotin je peux
vous résumer les objectifs de ce projet
de loi à travers un triptique simple
accéléré et simplifié conformément à
l'orientation donnée par le Président de
la République mardi dernier lors de sa
conférence de
presse lutter contre les marchands de
sommeil et améliorer les conditions de
vie des Françaises et des Français qui
vivent en copropriété ce qui représente
10 millions de logements pour répondre à
ces trois objectifs le projet de loi que
je porte aujourd'hui structure autour de
deux axes d'une part faciliter
l'intervention le plus en amont possible
afin d'éviter la dégradation définitive
et accélérer les procédures de recyclage
et de transformation des quartiers le
premier axe c'est d'intervenir le plus
tôt possible afin de mettre un terme
précoce aux spirales de dégradation pour
cela nous proposons notamment la
création du prê collectif aux
copropriétés il vise à faciliter le
financement bancaire des travaux dans
toutes les copropriétés de France cette
mesure répond à une attente très forte
des copropriétaires qui se retrouve
démuni face à l'absence de financement
ou à l'obligation de devoir attendre
plus d'un an et demi pour l'obtenir ce
n'est évidemment pas la seule mesure je
vais en citer quelques une rapidement et
je resterai à votre disposition pour
rentrer dans leur détails lors de
l'examen article par article mais je
veux signaler l'extension du périmètre
de la procédure d'opération de
restauration immobilière qui est
aujourd'hui pensé pour les centres
anciens je veux mettre l'accent sur la
meilleure information des
copropriétaires présents et futur ainsi
que des occupants sur l'état de leur
copropriété pour protéger les acheteurs
je veux insister sur l'introduction de
l'insaisabilité des comptes pour les
copropriétés sous-administration
judiciaire ou encore sur
l'enrichissement du régistre national
des copropriétés avec
l'introduction dans ce régistre des
diagnosticques de performance
énergétique simplifier et accélérer les
procédures judiciaires et
administrative ça reviendra à améliorer
le traitement des situations dramatiques
en matière de sécurité et de salubrité
ainsi que la réactivité de la puissance
publique en ajustant la procédure
d'expropriation en cas de danger
d'effondrement imminent le texte
contient également des mesures pour
accélérer les opérations d'aménagement
importantes notamment en matière de
numérisation des
procédures à l'heure où vos travaux
débutent en séance publique j'aimerais
saluer
le travail déjà effectué en commission
j'aimerais saluer le consensus politique
qui a pu se dégager sur un grand nombre
de points du texte le travail
constructif de presque tous les groupes
qui a permis de retenir des amendements
enrichissants et d'obtenir un vote
favorable sur le texte à l'unanimité des
présents en
commission je salue l'énorme travail qui
a été fait en amont de la présentation
de ce projet de loi avec les élus locaux
car ce texte est aussi le leur il
reprend de très nombreuses propositions
pragmatiques issues de 5 années
d'expérience du plan initiative
copropriété et du rapport
lutstin sur la lutte contre l'habitat
indigne mesdames et messieurs j'espère
vous avoir montré à quel point ce texte
est nécessaire à quel point il est utile
et j'espère que nos débats seront la
hauteur de la gravité des enjeux et que
la cause que nous servons la dignité des
Français et des Françaises et la
promesse humaniste et sociale de notre
République je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à monsieur Guillaume Vilet rapporteur de
la commission des affaires
[Applaudissements]
économiques madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques mon cher corrapporteur
Monsieur notre collègue Royer per mes
chers collègues cette majorité mène de
depuis 2017 une action constante pour
pour s'attaquer au problèmes de la
dégradation de l'habitat dans certains
quartiers de nos métropoles et de nos
petites villes il s'agit d'un enjeu
essentiel à la fois pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des habitants pour
dégager des viviers de logement dans une
époque où leur attrition pose des
problèmes dans les zones fragiles et
pour veiller à une meilleure adaptation
écologique énergétique de l'habitat au
défis climatiques 400000 logements et 1
million de personnes seraient concernées
ces dégradation ont un coût social
économique et environnement mental qui
n'est plus supportable ces mesures
donneront aux collectivités et au
copropriétaires des outils efficaces
pour faciliter la restauration des bâtis
quand il en est encore temps accélérer
les dispositifs existants et enfin
protéger les habitants des marchands de
sommeil notamment ce projet de loi
s'inscrit dans la lignée de la loi du 23
novembre 2018 portant sur l'évolution du
logement et l'aménagement numérique du
territoire la loi élan par la suite sous
l'égide du ministre Julien de Normandie
nous avons développé des programmes
d'action action de ville les petites
villees de demain afin de faciliter et
souten
le travail des collectivités locales
d'inciter les acteurs du logement et de
l'urbanisme à réinvestir les
centres-villees à favoriser le maintien
ou l'implantation d'activité et
globalement améliorer les conditions de
vie des habitants dans le cadre créé par
cette loi j'ai rédigé en 2019 à la
demande du Premier ministre un rapport
intitulé promouvoir l'habitabilité
durable pour tous qui a conduit à
l'ordonnance du 26 septembre 2020
relative à l'harmonisation et la
simplification des polices des immeubles
celle-ci a permis une une simplification
notable passant de 13 polies
administratives et 21 procédures à deux
policices administratives et quatre
procédures je tiens aussi à saluer le
travail d'Emmanuel vargon qui à la suite
de ce qu'avait fait Julien de Normandie
qui était de mettre la production neuve
au même niveau que la réhabilitation a
choisi à développer la notion de
d'enjeux énergétique dans la transition
du logement dans le même esprit les
oliviers les ministres Olivier cllein et
Patrice vergrit ont voulu renforcer les
moyens opérationnels à la disposition
des collectivités de l'État et des
opérateurs pour mener les des programmes
de recalification dehabitat indigne
c'est dans cet esprit qu'une mission a
été confiée au maire Mathieu anotin et
Michel Lutz danst les recommandations
ont largement nourri le projet de loi
que nous examinons aujourd'hui au cours
de nos auditions nous avons pu mesurer
avec mon corrapporteur Lionel Roy
etperro combien ces dispositions sont
attendues par les acteurs du secteur ces
dernières respectent notre feuille de
route pour suivant trois objectifs
anticiper accélérer et protéger ces
nouveaux outils complétant les les
mesures existantes permettront de lutter
efficacement contre l'habitat indigne et
les compropriétés dégradées je salue à
ce titre l'esprit souvent sans
transpartisant l de notre examen en
commission des affaires économiques
validant et renforçant ce texte dans
l'intérêt des Français dans la partie
que je rapporte je veux en particulier
souligner certains des apports du texte
qui exerceront à mon esprit une
influence particulièrement facilitatrice
dans la prise en charge de ces
situations difficiles l'article 3 crée
une nouvelle faculté pour les
collectivités d'exproprier des immeubles
qui sont dans un état de dégradation
encore remédiable ce qui doit permettre
de s'attaquer plus en amont aux
problématiques de dégradation et donc
d'éviter des des dédragations tellement
définitives qu'elles obligent à la
diminution d'immeuble ce faisant cela
permet d'éviter le traumatisme qui
existe pour les habitants de devoir
partir de chez eux cela aussi est
économe en argent public et cela
renforce l'efficacité de notre action
les articles 6 et 7 permettront de
faciliter l'intervention des opérateurs
spécialisés dans les actions de
recalification par la mobilisation de la
concession d'aménagement et du droit de
préemption qui peuvent actuellement
rencontrer des obstacles juridiques les
articles 11 et 12 apportent quant à eux
des des sécurisations bienvenues aux
procédures d'expropriation existante en
outre lors de l'examen en commission
nous avons enrichi le texte de plusieurs
dispositions dont je suis certain qu'
contribueront à améliorer encore le
traitement de ces situations c'est le
cas par exemple de l'article 8 bis appr
prend de l'article 8 bis qui crée la
faculté pour une commune de définir des
secteurs à risque dans lequels la
réalisation d'un diagnostic de structure
desim bâti est obligatoire afin de mieux
connaître et prévenir l'émergence de
difficultés sur les bâtiments à
l'article 7 bis nous avons créé la
possibilité de dispenser d' de permis de
construire les opérations temporaires
d'hébergement à destination des
personnes délogées à l'occasion de d'une
opération de realification qui doit
permettre d'accélérer sensiblement les
projets aux articles 12 et 12 TER nous
avons renforcé les effets des arrêtés de
traitement de l'insécurité ou de mise en
sécurité pour prévenir notamment les
agissements frauduleux ainsi par exemple
de l'organisation de la vacance de
l'immeuble pour éviter d'avoir à prendre
les mesures prescrites notamment qui
sont un comportement qui viiendra
impossible dans le même temps nous avons
veillé à transformer les outils de
prévention de la survellance des
dégradations notamment par la création
de l'article 5 bis d'un agrément le
syndic d'intérêt collectif qui permettra
à des opérateurs spécialisés par exemple
desilleurs sociaux de prêter leur
soutien aux compropriétés c'est donc un
outil plein instrument utile et
pertinent pour mieux résorber l'habitat
dégradé dont nous apprêtons à discuter
et j'espère que nous saons encore le
renforcer au cours de ces débats dans un
esprit qui restera je l'espère le plus
consensuel possible je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Lionel Royer Perro rapporteur de la
commission des affaires
[Applaudissements]
économiques bien madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission mon cher
collègu corapporteur cher Guillaume
vilté mesdames et messieurs les députés
mes chers collègues
le texte que nous examinons ce matin cet
après-midi concerne les copropriétés
dégradées c'est un texte qui pourrait
apparaître aux yeux de certains comme
étant trop juridique trop technique et
pourtant c'est un texte éminemment
politique c'est un texte éminemment
politique car il touche tout simplement
au quotidien de nos administrés il
touche tout simplement à la condition
d'habit ilité de d'à peu près
1500000 logements de gens qui
aujourd'hui vivent dans ces conditions
des conditions indignes des conditions
indécentes des conditions qui ne peuvent
faire honneur à notre pays et qui
nécessitent que les législateurs que
nous sommes et bien soyons en tant
capacité de modifier la loi pour faire
en sorte que les outils qui sont à notre
disposition et qui existent depuis
maintenant 30 ans et bien ces outils
puissent être adaptés que ces outils
puissent être modernisé que les
procédures puissent être simplifiées et
je crois que nous le devons avant toute
chose à celles et ceux qui vivent dans
ces situations nous le devons aussi à
ces élus qui se battent au quotidien
pour lutter dans leur territoire sur
contre l'habitat indigne contre
l'habitat indescent contre celles et
ceux qui font marchandise en quelque
sorte de la précarité nous le devons
finalement à notre pays pour que nous
ayons toutes et tous la capacité
d'offrir à aux françaises aux Français
des conditions dignees d'habitat alors
les outils je vous le disais chers
collègues ils existent depuis maintenant
quasiment 30 ans nous avons des lois qui
ont été voté qui se sont quasi
sédimentés les unes aux autres la
première étant en 1991 avec les fameuses
opération d'habitat et nous avons année
après année densifier notre législation
pour justement lutter contre l'habitat
indigne nous avons délibéré pour adopter
les plans de sauvegarde pour adopter les
orcodes pour adopter les plans de
rénovation urbaines pour adopter un plan
d'initiative copropriété ça a été dit
tout à l'heure par mon collègue vilt
bref toutes mesures qui permettent de
lutter contre l'habitat indigne et
pourtant nous savons que tous ces outils
sont ment complexe que tous ces outils
quelquefois s'enchevêtrre que tous ces
outils mis bout à bout et bien nous
n'arrivons pas nécessairement dans
certains territoires à lutter
efficacement contre l'habitat indine
c'est vrai en Île-de-France c'est vrai
en provenel C d'Azure mais c'est vrai à
dire vrai dans un certain nombre
d'autres régions et donc notre
responsabilité c'est précisément de
prendre les outils de faciliter les
règles pour aider les élus dans les
territoires
pour lutter plus efficacement pour
pénaliser plus fortement les marchands
de sommeil alors ce texte il compose il
comporte plusieurs articles qui me
semble-t-il vont faciliter vont aider
vont permettre de balayer le spectre à
360°r
lescopropriétés qui fonctionnent plutôt
bien lescopropriété qui commence à
émettre des signaux faibles et pour
lesquels il faut que la puissance
publique soit déjà présente à le côté
pour les accompagner et puis les
copropriétés qui bien évidemment sont
déjà en situation dégradée très dégradé
trop dégradé et là notre rôle bien
évidemment c'est de les accompagner
alors ça peut passer par le prè
collectif solidaire cela a été dit par
Monsieur le Ministre ça peut passer bien
évidemment par
l'insaisissabilité des sommes versé à la
Caisse des dépôts pour les
copropriétaires c'est un deuxè volet ça
peut passer par l'extension des
conditions d'ouverture du mandat ad hoc
ça peut passenser par l'amélioration de
la connaissance du parc de copropriété
notamment en permettant à ce que le
registre d'immatriculation intègre le
DPE ça peut passer par l'information des
copropriétés et occupants des euh euh
sur les procédures de lHI et ça peut
passer aussi par la sission d'un certain
nombre de copropriétés en matière
d'orcode ou voir de plan de sauvegarde
bless ce sont toutes ces actions mises
bout à bout qui pourront nous aider à
lutter contre l'habitat indigne et
quelque part je me réjouis de l'état
d'esprit qui a animé notre commission
car ce débat ce débat doit se placer en
dehors des contingences politiciennes je
pense que notre responsabilité
collective individuelle c'est de faire
fi de nos oppositions au traditionnel
d'ici dans cet hémicycle qui peut
s'avérer quelquefois bruillant pour
précisément faire en sorte que nous
soyons en capacité d'être au rendez-vous
des exigences et des attentes de nos
administrés c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous aurons très largement
l'occasion de débattre de l'ensemble des
amendements à ce
Tex la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
casbarion président de la commission des
affaires
[Applaudissements]
économiques
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues je me réjoui que nous
débutions aujourd'hui l'examen de ce
projet de loi qui constitue donc le
premier texte du nouveau gouvernement
dirigé par Gabriel Atal c'est un signal
important que ce premier texte inscrit à
l'ordre du jour porte sur le logement et
je remercie le ministre Christophe Béchu
de le porter avec force et conviction
j'observe aussi que le groupe LFI s
pront à réclamer des lois en matière de
logement c'est surtout fait remarquer
par son absence totale lors de la
discussion des articles en commission
tous ces membres étant parti après
l'intervention de l'oratrice du groupe
dans la discussion générale il s'agit
pourtant d'un projet de loi utile plein
d'avancées concrètes pour les élus et
les habitants qui s'inscrit dans les pas
de notre action continuelle en la
matière depuis la loi élan en matière de
lutte contre l'habitat dégradé et les
marchands de sommeil je veux
particulièrement saluer le travail de
nos rapporteurs Lionel Royer Perro et
Guillaume V qui a d'ailleurs reproduit
en 2019 un rapport ayant mené à une
profonde simplification de ce régime en
2020 le texte du projet de loi peut
apparaître technique vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur mais en réalité
il reprend un ensemble de propositions
concrètes faites par deux élus de
terrain deux maires confrontés à ces
problèmme Michel Lutz maire de mulouse
et Mathieu anotin maire de Saint-Denis
le texte constitue dans sa version
déposée une boîte à outils très attendu
par les collectivités territoriales
puisqu'elle renforce les facultés à la
main des communes des zepci et et de
leurs opérateurs pour mener leur projets
le texte comprend aussi dans son article
14 plusieurs accélérations procédurales
que je salue pour les opérations
d'intérêt national qui permettront donc
de mener plus efficacement des grandes
opérations d'aménagement y compris la
production de logements qui leur est
associé d're Commission avait déjà eu
l'an dernier une attention particulière
dans les lois nucléaires zan et
industrie verte pour dynamiser la
production de logements associés à des
grands projets d'envergure national et
d'intérêt général c'est absolument
indispensable pour notre
réindustrialisation et donc cet article
va dans le même sens et va permettre
d'accélérer les choses notre commission
a fait un beau travail sur ce texte en
acceptant de nombreux amendements de la
majorité comme de l'opposition
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre vous
avez noté un vote à l'unanimité des
membres présents de notre commission je
m'en réjouis et ce travail transpartisan
permet de porter le texte de 17 articles
initialement à 29 articles et donc nos
débats nous ont permis d'apporter encore
plus de simplification à ce texte
l'article 7 bis qui a été créé par nos
rapporteurs permettra d'accélérer les
projets de requalification et
d'aménagement en déployant des
constructions d'hébergement temporaire
jusqu'à 5 ans il s'agit d'une avancée
qui accélérera les opérations de
résorption l'article 9 ter créé par
notre collègue Lionel Kos assoupli les
règles de vote pour l'adoption d'un
programme de travaux de rénovation
énergétique dans la copropriété c'est
une avancée importante qui facilitera
l'atteintre des objectifs exigeants que
nous nous sommes fixés en matière de
rénovation thermique des bâtiments des
amendements proposés en séance
permettront je pense de rendre cette
disposition encore plus opérationnelle
dans le plein respect des droits
descopropriét
je me réjouis également de l'adoption
d'un article 3 bis par notre collègue
benjamin saint-uile du groupe Yot qui va
permettre de lutter encore plus
efficacement contre l'artificialisation
illicite des sols en ouvrant aux
autorités publiques le moyen de mettre
en œuvre d'office des mesures pour
résorber les problèmes d'insécurité ou
d'insalubrités qui sont suscités par des
constructions illégales je veux
également évoquer les diverses mesures
de simplification des relations entre
syndicque et copropriétés qui sont porté
à l'article 9 bis en particulier la
disposition qui est proposée par notre
collègue Sandra Marceau
élargissant les possibilités de
dématérialisation pour les notifications
et mis en demeure le lien entre les
dispositions de l'article 9 bis et même
celle de l'article 9 ter avec le projet
initial aurait pu peut-être être
interrogé mais j'ai bien noté que il y
avait un grand nombre d'amendements de
nos collègues sur le sujet et donc n
j'ai adopté une approche assez large sur
la question et je me réjouis que la
séance a adopté cette même approche
large sur la recevabilité ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir des débats
riches aujourd'hui et demain et le reste
de la semaine il reste bien évidemment
beaucoup à faire pour apporter des
réponses à la crise profonde du logement
d'autres textes arriveront prochainement
je pense notamment à une proposition du
groupe démocrate et de Romain d'ubier
sur la transformation de bureaux en
logement que nous étudierons mercredi
matin en commission je pense aussi à la
poursuite de l'examen de la proposition
de loi visant à remédier au déséquilibre
du marché locatif de nos collègues
annaiglemer etaki et tanise la semaine
dernière le président de la République a
annoncé de grosse simplification à venir
pour réduire les délais accélérer les
procédures éviter les recours multiples
et et remettre de l'audace et de
l'énergie dans le secteur du logement
nul doute que de beaux chantiers
législatifs nous attendent dans les mois
qui viennent monsieur le ministre et
chers collègues nous serons au
rendez-vous de ce beau défi je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
nous en venons à la discussion général
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu
pour le groupe gauche démocrate
républicaine
nupes
si vous autoriser madame la Présidente
je
voudrais comme député de Saint-Denis
avant de démarrer mon propos sur la
proposition de loi avoir une pensée pour
la la famille les proches les camarades
les enseignants du jeune Sedan 14 ans et
et Fari 17 ans qui sont tous les deux
morts la semaine dernière à Saint dans
des des
Rix madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues notre pays traverse une
crise du logement d'une ampleur inédite
depuis 30 ans le nombre de ménages en
attente d'allogement social n'a jamais
été aussi élevé et la
construction jamais étit aussi faible
depuis 25 ans le nombre de personnes
sans domicile a doublé en 10 ans et
aujourd'hui 3000 enfants dorment chaque
nuit dans la rue tandis que 18 % de la
population habite à un logement pouvant
être considéré comme unalubre l'accès à
la propriété pour les classes moyennes
n'a de son côté enfin jamais été aussi
faible et inégalitaire socialement
malgré cette situation alarmante le
président de la République et le Premier
ministre n'ont pas jugé bon de doter le
logement d'un ministère de plein de
plein exercice cela augure mal de la
suite et de la capacité comme de la
volonté de ce nouveau gouvernement
d'apporter enfin des réponses adaptées à
cette crise du logement que subit notre
pays le texte soumis à notre examen
aujourd'hui a au regard de ces enjeux
une ambition modeste mais c'est un texte
nous l'avons dit en commission c'est un
texte utile il propose quelques avancées
et s'appuie pour pour le faire sur des
retours d'expérience des opérateurs et
des élus locaux cela fait des années que
nous réclamons avec d'autres des moyens
techniques et juridiques permettant
d'accélérer les procédures et intervenir
en amont sur les propriété fragile ou
dégradé avant que la situation ne
devienne irréédiable nous accueillons
donc avec satisfaction certaines des
mesures emblématiques de ce texte comme
la nouvelle procédure d'expropriation
dérogatoire ou en cas d'inaction des
propriétaires ou les mesures visant à
accélérer et sécuriser les opérations de
requalification nous en demeurons
cependant toujours au même constat
malgré les lois qui se sont succédées
depuis plus de 20 20 ans nous avons
toujours pas fini nous n'en avons
toujours pas fini avec les maisons qui
tuent et avec la dégradation du parc
descopropriété la moitié de ce parc date
des années 50 à 80 et nécessite des
investissements lourds pour les
maintenir en état les remettre à niveau
et en améliorer la performance
énergétique les causes de
l'accroissement de ces difficultés des
difficultés de ces copropriétés ne
tiennent cependant pas seulement à la
fin de ce que l'on nomme le cycle
technique de ces immeubles elles sont
aussi à chercher dans la popérisation
accrue des propriétaires occupants
personnes âgées ou primo accédent
modestes ou encore dans le comportement
de certains propriétaires bailleurs qui
considèrent leur bien uniquement comme
un produit financier source de
rentabilité et rien d'autre en tout cas
pas comme un bien patrimonial ainsi
certaines copropriétés atteignent un
taux d'impayé supérieur ou égal à 25 %.
c'est pourquoi devant l'ampleur des
difficultés nous ne pouvons pas en
rester à l'accumulation de dispositifs
juridiques sans moyens humains et
budgétaires renouvelés or votre texte
fait l'impasse sur les questions
financières et sociales il reste par
ailleurs trop timide sur des questions
essentielles à nos yeux celles de la
lutte contre les marchands de sommeil
celle du et celle du pouvoir exorbitant
des propriétaires bailleurs qui parfois
paralysent les travaux celle de la
politique d'investissement public et de
construction de logement social seul à
même d'assécher le marché noir du
logement sur lequel prospère l'habitat
indigne
nous avions comme d'autres groupes
déposé des amendements en commission
pour élargir le débat et nous attaquer
aux causes profondes des difficultés que
connaissent aujourd'hui les copropriétés
dégradées et leurs occupants alors si on
a pu avoir un débat très constructif et
je je souscris à ce qui a été dit sur le
sujet nous regrettons néanmoins que
beaucoup de nos amendements n'ai pas été
jugés receva au motif qui serait sans
lien avec le texte qui nous semblait pas
être le cas il est urgent en effet de
mettre un coup d'arrêt à la à la
comptabilité morbide du nombre de
victimes des tudis insalues qui
émaillent régulièrement l'actualité
comme ce fut le cas encore récemment il
y a quelques semaines à grgny quand
j'étais au responsable aux
responsabilités à la mairie de
SaintDenis j'ai en 12 ans de 2000 à 2012
étaé témoins de 25 décès liés à
l'insalubrité dont 13 enfants et
d'autres depuis sont décédés pour les
mêmes raisons alors oui il est possible
de concevoir des dispositifs beaucoup
plus coheritif que ceux qui existent
aujourd'hui pour garantir à chacun comme
le veut notre Constitution la protection
de la santé la sécurité et le repos dans
un logement digne nous voterons ce texte
mais nous espérons que nos débats nous
permettront némins encore de l'améliorer
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis bricou pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre M et
territoire merci Madame prés présidente
monsieur le ministre messieurs les
présidents de commission monsieur le
Président de la Commission et Messieurs
les rapporteurs gouverner c'est d'abord
loger son peuple c'est avec ces mots
puissants que laabé Pierre exhorta toute
sa vie les pouvoirs publics à sortir de
l'inaction à créer les conditions du
partage à fonder une société où chacune
chacun a le droit à un habitat digne en
2024 les enjeux climatiques les enjeux
économiques les dégâts sociaux auxquels
nous devons faire face nous oblige
collectivement parce que le constat sur
le parc de logement dégradé est
largement partagé il fallait que cette
loi puisse être examiner travailler et
améliorer je veux ici saluer les
propositions que Michel Lutz et Mathieu
anotin ont formulé auprès du
gouvernement à travers eux c'est
l'implication des élus et des
collectivités qui doit être soulignée je
veux aussi saluer le travail des
rapporteurs fait de volonté et de
sincérité je saluais enfin la grande
qualité des débats en commission pour
autant parce qu'il faut être juste et
avoir un minimum de mémoire nous pouvons
regretter qu'il est fallu attendre que
des immeubles s'effondrent à Marseille
et ailleurs pour qu'il y ait une réponse
à ces drames de la misère sociale
partout dans les territoires hexagonaux
et d'outrem dans les quartiers
populaires les grandes agglomérations
comme dans les centres Bour en ruralité
d'ailleurs des immeubles se détériorent
les problèmes auxquels les
copropriétaires sont exposés sont
souvent les mêmes des difficultés de
gestion des impayés de charg qui se
cumulent des travaux reportés cette
concentration de dysfonctionnement a des
conséquences très concrètes elle est
synonyme de logement souvent vétus pour
ne pas dire indigne d'immeubles qui
tombent en décrépitude voire qui
s'effondre de quartiers qui perdent en
attractivité ceux qui le peuvent
d'ailleurs quittent ses logements ces
immeubles il ne reste bien souvent que
les ménages les plus précaires enfermés
dans des logements devenus dangereux et
dans une une spirale de popérisation ces
situations sont évidemment inacceptables
dans un pays comme le nôtre aujourd'hui
nous nous devons d'ajouir puissamment et
ce projet de loi permettra aux
collectivités et aux opérateurs
d'intervenir le plus en amant possible
parce qu'il nous faut éviter les drames
humains et sociaux ce texte prévoit
aussi des mesures de bon sens attendu
depuis longtemps au groupe lot nous
sommes notamment favorables à la
nouvelle procédure d'expropriation pour
les immeubles dégradés dont l'état est
remédiable à la réhabilitation des
copropriétés avant que la situation ne
soit critique au droit de préemption
urbain renforcé demandé par les élus à
la Sion des grands ensembles en
plusieurs syndicats pour faciliter la
tâche des opérateurs j'ai l'occasion de
le dire en commission que plusieurs
dispositions gagneraient en revanche à
être retravaillé s'agissant de l'emprunt
global collectif pour le financement de
travaux dans les copropriétés nous
redoutons que des établissements
financiers ne prêtent au au copropriétés
en difficulté la mise en place d'une
garantie publique s'impose le
gouvernement d'ailleurs a déposé un
amendement en ce sens nous y serons
favorables reste désormais à préciser de
combien sera abondé le fond pour
répondre aux besoins des copropriétés et
encadrer ses conditions de recours rien
ne rien de pire serait que devoir
garantir la solvabilité des marchands de
sommeil ses profiteurs de logement
indécent vous le savez
pour tous les autres propriétaires
modestes et très modestes le réseau
bancaire traditionnel n'est pas au
rendez-vous de la rénovation voilà
pourquoi il faut renforcer
l'accompagnement public voilà pourquoi
je me ferai toujours défenseur d'une
banque de la rénovation et on touche
maintenant aux carences du projet de loi
les marchands de sommeil peuvent en
effet dormir sur leurs deux oreilles les
mesures coercitiv ne font pas légion le
droit ne peut qu'exister en humanité
c'est-à-dire s'appuyer sur des des
principes de justice l'égalité il en va
de la promesse républicaine je pourrais
parler aussi de l'absence de repérage et
d'accompagnement des copropriétés qui
sont en difficulté et pas encore dégradé
de l'insuffisance de nouvelles
informations au registre national
d'immatriculation des copropriétés ou
encore de l'absence d'éléments
concernant l'accompagnement en
ingénierie et financier alors que la
prise en charge opérationnelle de la
lutte contre l'habitat indigne pèse sur
les budgets enfin monsieur le ministre
nous ne pourrons pas faire l'économie
d'une loi qui qui traite de l'habitat
dégradé en
ruralité les biens sans MRE les biens en
désérance les biens en abandon manifeste
c'est une réalité qu'il nous faudra
traiter rapidement je pense à l'heure où
la loisane inquiète les élus de nos
campagnes sur leur capacité à se
développer je vous remerci merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Sandra Marsau pour le groupe
Renaissance
Mame la
présidente merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues les copropriétés
sont une préoccupation majeure des
politiques de
l'habitat le parc ancien des logements
s'avère souvent véuste ça a déjà été dit
parfois insalubre et souvent doté
d'équipement énergivor et ceci
d'ailleurs dans tout type de quartiers
de nos villes des centres anciens à des
quartiers plus
contemporains ce sont plus d'un million
de logement même 1500000 vous l'avez
chacun d'entre vous rappelé qui présente
des signes de forte fragilité nous et
nous devons malheureusement déplorer des
événements tragiques où des immeubles se
sont effondrés faisant de avec eux des
VI alors les pouvoirs publics se sont
employés depuis les années 90 à peu près
à soutenir les propriétaires dans des
démarches de rénovation de
requalification pour répondre aussi bien
des questions juridiques urbaines
d'ingénierie bien entendu aussi à des
questions sociales il n'en reste pas
moins beaucoup de blocage des procédures
aussi très longues et le texte présenté
ici
essaie d'apporter de de nouvelles
solutions pour remédier à des
problématies à ces problématiques et R
la capacité à agir de la puissance
publique puisque c'est bien d'elle aussi
dont on parle dans ce texte en 2018 avec
la loi han sous l'impulsion du ministre
du Logement que je salue celui de
l'époque Julien de Normandie nous avons
mis en place des moyens permettant
d'améliorer le fonctionnement des
copropriétés et le traitement des plus
dégradés le gouvernement avait alors
lancé un plan d'action sur 10 ans le
fameux plan initiative copropriété pour
accélérer le processus de de
redressement justement de de ces
copropriétés en grande difficulté ce
plan porté par l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat mais aussi je je les salue par
nombre d'opérateurs et parmi eux des
urbanistes s'appuie sur une action
renforcée et coordonné de l'ensemble des
partenaires nationaux et locaux pour
apporter des solutions adaptées au
territoire aujourd'hui le projet de loi
que nous examinons s'inscrit euh à la
fois dans le cadre de différents
rapports qui ont été cités euh le direct
de la case des dépôts sur le prê
collectif mais aussi des maires et aussi
dans la perspective de prolonger ce plan
initiative copropriété et il traduit
juridiquement le retour d'expérience des
opérateurs que j'ai cité et des acteurs
impliqués dans l'habitat
dégradé ce projet de loi s'attache en
conséquence à moderniser les outils à la
main des collectivités des opérateurs
pour permettre une intervention le plus
en amont possible tout en garantissant
la bonne fin des opérations de
requalification de ces copropriét et le
cas échéant par voie d'expropriation il
s'agit de faciliter l'intervention des
collectivités des pouvoirs publics
lorsque cela s'avère nécessaire en
élargissant le champ des travaux pouvoir
faire l'objet d'une opération de
restauration immobilière à l'article 1er
en simplifiant l'ouverture de la
procédure du mandat ad hoc qui permet de
rresser redresser les copropriétés en
mauvaise gestion financière à l'article
5 en créant un régime de concession
spécifique aux copropriétés dégradé à
l'article 6 en facilitant le recours au
droit de préemption urbain dans le cadre
du traitement de ces dernières à
l'article 7 le projet de loi permet
également euh la cission de très grandes
copropriété en plusieurs syndiques ce
qui aura pour avantage d'optimiser la
gestion de du redressement de ces
dernières à l'article 10 et il simplifie
la reconnaissance de l'état de carence à
l'article 13 en commission nous avons
adopté un certain nombre de dispositions
pour enrichir ce texte nous avons
notamment renforcé l'arsenal juridique
cont contre les marchands de sommeil en
renforçant la peine encourue pour par
ces derniers et en clarifiant la
définition juridique de cette infraction
à l'article 8 terre nous avons également
créé un déli de location irrégulière
dissimulé c'est-à-dire que nous
sanctionnons en tous les cas nous
souhaitons par ce texte le sanctionner
le paiement du loyer de la main à la
main sans délivrance de quittance
toujours dans le but de mieux cner ces
marchands de sommeil et ça c'est
l'article 8 quater par ailleurs nous
avons intégré des dispositions visant à
responsabiliser les syndiques notamment
en créant des syndicques euh avec des
agréments et en obligeant les sortants à
transmettre un certain nombre
d'informations sur les comptes de la
propriété au syndque entrant à l'article
9 bis enfin nous avons renforcé le
pouvoir des maèires afin qu'il puisse
intervenir plus en amant sur la
dégradation du bâti à l'article 3 bis en
facilitant la prise d'arrêté de mise en
sécurité eu égard au risque incendie à
l'article 12 bis et en leur permettant
de rendre obligatoire la la réalisation
d'un diagnostic structure de l'immeuble
à l'article 8 bis je tiens à préciser
que les dispositions adoptées émanai de
l'ensemble des groupes de cette
hémicycle et je salue cet esprit
constructif et je souhaite qu'il soit de
même en hémicycle je vous remercie merci
madame la députée la parole est à Madame
Christine EnGrande pour le groupe
rassemblement
national merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur chers
collègues la lutte contre l'habitat
dégradé est d'une importance capitale et
doit constituer la priorité de de la de
toute politique du logement responsable
depuis le milieu des années 90 la France
fait face à une augmentation alarmante
des situations d'urgence et des
copropriétés fragiles principalement
concentrées dans nos centr-villees
malgré cette réalité préoccupante les
gouvernements successifs n'ont pas
réussi à relever le défi posé par par la
dégradation de l'habitat créant ainsi un
besoin urgent de mesurees efficace le
projet de loi dans sa rédaction actuelle
contient certaines dispositions
positives en faveur de la réhabilitation
et de la simplification du financement
des travaux c'est le cas de l'incabilité
des comptes bancaires des copropriétés
en redressement cependant il est
indéiablement dévoyé par votre tendance
à porter atteinte aux libertés publiques
et en particulier au droit à la
propriété pour des considérations qui ne
se rapprochent ni de loin ni de près de
la habitat indigne ou
dégradé en témoignant en témoigne les
mentions insistantes à propos de la
rénovation énergétique au nom de
laquelle il serait presque légitime
d'exproprier un petit propriétaire ou de
lui imposer des travaux parce que son
logement n'est pas sanctionné de la
bonne lettre sur son diagnostic
énergétique diagnostics qui soit dit en
passant ont été éplinglés le 10 janvier
dernier par le Conseil d'analyse
économique et sociale pour leur manque
d'objectivité soyons donc clair
l'habitat indigne et dégradé ce n'est
pas avoir un un DPE class eu l'habitat
indigne c'est lorsque le gouvernement
fait passer un décret cet été qui permet
de louer des logements avec une hauteur
sous plafond d' 1,80 les les heureux
propriétaires d'une cave vous en
remercient pas les locataires l'habitat
indigne c'est lorsque les bailleurs
sociaux gèrent tout un parc de logement
moisi et le loup sans sourciller à des
personnes qui n'ont pas d'autres
alternativ l'habitat dégradé c'est quand
l'on se rend compte qu'un internat doit
être évacué parce que sa structure est
branlante c'est lorsque deux immeubles
s'effondrent en plein ville de Lille et
coûte la vie à un médecin les élus
locaux qui sont en première ligne dans
la gestion de l'habitat dégradé
attendent des dispositives flexibles
leur permettant de surmonter les les
lourdeurs normatives qui entravent leur
capacité d'intervention rapide par des
outils protéiformes adapté par le groupe
présidentiel selon sa lubie du moment et
rendu incompréhensible et inutilisable
par leur complexité ainsi il est
regrettable de constater que ce texte ne
répond pas suffisamment à bien à ce
souci de simplifier ation de
clarification et d'efficacité
qu'appellent les élus locaux et qu'il
bafouent les quelques suggestions faites
par des associations de crpropriétaire
il semble s'inscrire dans une vision
politique où la propriété immobilière
est réprouvée une telle approche risque
de transformer la France en un pays de
locataire mobile composé de citoyens
privé de la possibilité de construire un
patrimoine immobilier et réduit à la
qualité d'agent économique géré et
déplacés à l'envie selon la situation
économique au nom d'une conception
particulière de la modernité dont vous
êtes les prédicateurs en outre il est
particulement inter il est
particulièrement inquiétant que le
gouvernement semble avoir délibérment
négligé les représentants des
copropriétaires ces derniers ont subi
une augmentation significative de leur
charge atteignant une hausse de 50 % en
10 ans l'application aveugle de ce texte
pourrait en fait intensifier la
fragilité des copropriétés exposant
certains copropriétaires occup au risque
de surendettement ce qui aggraverait la
les disparités
socio-économiques de plus les
dispositifs proposés négligent la la
protection nécessaire des bâtiments à
fort intérêt historique ou architectural
en privilégiant des critères directement
économiques ou environnementaux le
projet de loi ignore des aspects
culturels et patrimoniaux essentiels à
la préservation de notre histoire et de
notre identité qui ne sont pourtant pas
antinomiques d'un logement décent et
intègre en l'état nous considérons donc
que ce texte manque d'ambition et que
ses sorties de route répété sur un sujet
qui devrait être une des priorités de la
politique du logement sont inadmissibles
aussi nous appellerons à supprimer tous
les articles de loi attentant de manière
disproportionné Hut égard aux objectifs
poursuivis à nos libertés chères en
espérant qu'en résulte une rédaction
plus équilibrée nous appelons donc à une
réflexion approfondie et à la mise en
place de mesures mieux calibrées pour
faire face efficacement à la
problématique de l'habitat dégradé dans
d'autres pays nous pensons qu'il est de
notre responsabilité collective de
garantir une politique du longement
équitable respectueuse des droits
fondamentaux des citoyens tout en
répondant de manière efficace au défis
de l'habitat dégradé merci merci madame
la députée la parole est à Monsieur
William Martinet pour le groupe la
France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
nupes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
logement indigne est pour le peuple une
grande cause de souffrance le vent le
froid et l'humidité qui s'infiltre dans
le foyer la moisissure qui noircit les
murs les fissures qui lésardent le
plafond l'escalier qui menace de
s'effondrer les détritures qui
s'accumule et attire les nuisibles la
nuit qui se passe dans l'angoisse d'un
incendie qui pourrait vous emporter vous
et vos enfants voilà ce que vivent des
millions de femmes et d'hommes dans
notre pays pour eux le domicile qui
devrait être le lieu du repos de la
tranquillité du réconfort est en réalité
une source de malheur il use il épuise
il abîme le corps autant que l'esprit je
veux dire à ces familles que leur
souffrance est une honte pour le pays
tout entier la France est la 7e
puissance économique mondiale nous
sommes le trè pays au monde qui comporte
le plus de millionnaires l'année passée
les dividendes versées aux actionnaires
du CAC 40 ont atteint le record
historique de 97 milliards d'euros et à
côté de cette accumulation de richesse
absolument indécente il est révoltant de
constater que perdurent des îlos de
misère je parle de ces villages de ces
quartiers frappés par le logement
indigne où les marchands de sommeil font
la loi le texte que nous discutons
aujourd'hui a pour première faiblesse de
ne pas traiter la problématique du
logement indigne dans sa globalité mais
de le résumer à des mesures juridiques
techniques sur les copropriétés
dégradées il est vrai que sur ce sujet
il y a déjà beaucoup à dire et à
critiquer sur le bilan du gouvernement
citons le plan initiative copropriété
qui n'a consommé que 14 % de ses crédits
en 4 ans parlons de ces opération
d'intérêt national visant lespropriétés
les plus dégradées qui ne sont encore
que des coquieses vides j'ai pu le
constater en me rendant à Marseille à
l'invitation de mes collègues insoumis
Sébastien delogu em manuel bonpard le
président Macron était venu lui même
dans la cité fosséenne faire des
annonces mais les habitants des
copropriétés que j'ai rencontré à Félix
Piat consola ou la cité du maille
vivaient encore vivent encore et
toujours dans un logement indigne à
Marseille l'origine du problème est la
même qu'ailleurs l'abandon de l'État
abandon des propriétaires occupants seul
face à des coups d'entretien qui
explosent abandon des locataires
désemparés face à une situation qu'il ne
comprennent pas et leur échappe
totalement abandon face aux agissements
des marchands de sommeil qui refusent
d'assumer leur ch charge pour maximiser
leurs profit prenant en otage l'ensemble
des occupants ne soyons pas naïf si ce
système perdure ce n'est pas seulement
par manque de moyens ou du fait de la
complexité de la loi c'est parce que le
logement le logement indigne est un
business les marchands de sommeil qui
vivent de la misère sont bien souvent
les notables de la ville ils s'appuient
sur leur réseau leur connaissance de la
loi pour mieux la contourner et
manipuler des locataire vulnérabl face à
ce système il n'y a qu'une question qui
vaille allons-nous le combattre avec
force pour permettre aux habitants de
retrouver enfin leur dignité ce n'est
malheureusement pas avec cette loi donc
je le disais qu' qu'elle était technique
et il faut aussi rajouter sans moyens
budgétaire et humains ce n'est pas avec
cette loi que nous mènerons sérieusement
la bataille pire il faut dire que la
politique du logement menée par la
macronie parce qu'elle est propagateur
de misère est objectivement un soutien
au marchands de sommeil et au
développement de l'habitat indigne
baisser les APL augmenter les loyers
couper dans les les budget des bailleurs
sociaux et donc rallonger la liste des
demandeurs de logement social renforcer
les pouvoirs des multipropriétaires pour
mettre à la porte leurs locataires voilà
des mesures qui paupérisent et
affaiblissent les locataires les plaçant
à la mercie des marchands de sommeil
nous les insoumis reprenant les mots de
Victor Hugo pensons qu'il est possible
non pas seulement de diminuer amoindrir
limiter ou circonscrire le logement
indigne nous pensons qu'il est possible
de le faire disparaître la France de
2024 a les moyens d'éradiquer ce fléo
qui fait souffrir tant de nos
concitoyens à condition que les
gouvernants en aient la volonté pour
cela il faudrait un État fort un état
qui s'assure que le droit au logement
soit supérieur au privilèges des
multipropriétaires que les lois de
l'humanité soient au-dessus des lois de
la jungle imposées par les marchands de
sommeil voilà pourquoi nous proposons
par exemple la généralisation du permis
de louer c'est-à-dire que l'État avant
la mise en location contrôle la décence
du logement fini les larmes de
crocodiles des élus locaux et des
préfectures qui déplorent le cercle
vicieux de la dégradation d'une d'une
copropriété avec la généralisation du
permis de louer le logement est contrôlé
avant sa mise sur le marché et les
droits des locataires sont garantis
d'être respectés autre proposition le
durcissement des sanctions contre les
marchands de sommeil comprenant non
seulement la facilitation des
expropriations mais aussi l'interdiction
de mettre en location de nouveaux biens
être marchand de sommeil c'est faire
commerce de la misère s'enrichir du
malheur cela ne relève pas du simple
exercice de la propriété privée et cela
justifie en cas d'abus que l'État Pr de
mesures exceptionnelles dernière
proposition à destination des
propriétaires occupant mondest ils ont
acquis leur logement grâce au fruits de
leur travail et le cercle vicieux de
l'insalubrité peut les amener à tout
perdre nous proposons un soutien massif
de l'État pour des travaux de rénovation
énergétique avec reste à charge zéro
pour les ménages modestes voilà une
mesure qui débloquerait bien des
situations en conclusion je dirais ceci
l'éradication de l'habitat indigne est
autant possible que nécessaire mais cela
nécessite de la volonté politique cela
nécessite de voter favblement
merci merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur thibao
Bazin pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre en charge de la
transition écologique monsieur le
Président de la Commission les affaires
économiques messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues le gouvernement a
inscrit à l'ordre du jour ce projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération et à la
simplification de la rénovation de
l'habitat dégradé et des grandes
opérations d'aménagement le titre semble
porteur de promesses mais il n'y a même
pas à ce jour de ministre en charge du
logement alors que le secteur est en
crise l'exécutif ne semble pas avoir
pris la mesure de la gravité de la
situation et de l'urgence d'y remédier
ce n'est pas très sérieux cela témoigne
aussi du peu de considération apportée
par l'exécutif au au sujet du logement
qui n'apparaît pas au rang des priorités
nationales le gouvernement a manqué
l'occasion du budget pour 2024 pour
répondre à cette crise du logement au
lieu de mesure forte l'exécutif a
effectué de nouveau rabot sur le prêatau
zéro et imposé une évolution inquiétante
du dispositif ma prime Renov faisant
craindre encore moins de rénovation et
des sorties massives de logement du parc
locatif devant le mur calendaire de
l'interdiction de logement des mal
classés plus de 100000 coprpriétés sont
pourtant identifié comme étant en
fragilité auquell s'ajoute un nombre de
plus en plus important de
copropriétaires qui ont des difficulté à
payer les appels de fonds trimestriel
basculant en un payé de charge cette
situation s'est amplifiée avec les
exigences de travaux de rénovation y
compris énergétique nécessitant de
définir un cadre plus strict en matière
d'administration des copropriétés tout
en prévoyant des mesures plus
protectriistes à l'égard des
copropriétaire certes des mesures
techniques de ce projet de loi sur
l'habitat dégradé vont dans le bon sens
par exemple une définition plus large à
l'article 1 des opérations de
restauration immobilière mais est-ce que
l'ensemble de ce projet est la hauteur
des défis actuels pour le logement
dégradé malheureusement non en l'état
actuel du projet les articles semblent
insuffisants pour répondre efficacement
aux objectifs d'accélération de la
rénovation des copropriétés et du
redressement des immeubles dégradés il y
a de bonnes idées mais qui peuvent
s'avérer inopérantes ou presque ainsi
l'emprunt collective qui sera ainsi
facilité par article 2 pose des question
tous les copropriétaires même ceux qui
ne veulent pas en profiter seraient
tenus de participer à l'emprunt et de
participer au remboursement de l'emprunt
sur plusieurs années comment les
prêteurs et les organismes de caution
vont considérer les copropriétaires qui
serai inscrits au fichier des de
remboursement des crédits au
particuliers l'état va-t-il apporter des
garanties au copropriétaires défaillants
quelles conséquence sur le cautionnement
solidaire garantissant le syndicat quels
organismes accepteront de cautionner ce
risque avéré avec quel surcoût plus
généralement comment l'État va
accompagner les copropriétaires modeste
à faire face aux investissements
nécessaires pour assurer la transition
énergétique et là c'est c'est mon plus
grand regret ce projet de loi fait
l'impasse sur les moyens pour aider à la
rénovation de l'habitat dégradé à part
ce prêt collectif facilité qu'il faudra
rembourser concernant le financement des
copropriétés enjeu essentiel alors
qu'elles doivent adopter des programmes
plurannuels de travaux ne faut-il pas
plutôt maintenir le choix entre le
nouveau prê collectif à adhésion
obligatoire et les solutions existantes
de prê collectif à individuel autre
question suscité par votre projet
concernant le délai de paiement cash des
copropriétaires refusant le prêt ils
devront dans les 6 mois de la
notification verser l'intégralité de
leur code part du coût des travaux de
rénovation au syndicque or la pratique
montre que les délais de mise en place
des crédits collectifs actuels
sont largement supérieurs jusqu'à 18
mois ainsi le copropriétaire aurait
versé sa côte part sur un compte dédié
pour un crédit non mis en place le point
de départ des 6 mois ne devrait-il pas
être revu pour être cohérent avec la
réalité de la mise en place du crédit je
proposerai des amendements en ce sens
toutes ces questions m'incitent à penser
que le projet de loi en l'état n'est pas
abouti en témoigne les 18 amendements
déposés en dernièrees minutes par le
gouvernement sans sans nous avoir
concerté c'est c'est dommage alors que
nous sommes ouverts monsieur le ministre
aux discussions pour soutenir ce qui ira
dans le bon sens certes plusieurs
articles semblent très intéressants en
termes d'amélioration des procédures en
vue de l'expropriation ou de la
préemption quand cela se justifie mais
se pose la question de la suite quel
moyen pour les collectivités et leurs
opérateurs afin ensuite de rénover ses
logements dégradés en se saisissant de
ces outils combien d'immeubles en ruine
acquis par les collectivités peineent
déjà aujourd'hui à être réhabilité faute
de moyens plus compliqué encore dans les
immeubles en copropriété si la
collectivité devient propriétaire d'un
logement dégradé comment ensuite
va-t-elle interagir au sein de la
copropriété après l'avoir rénové
a-t-elle vocation à conserver ce
logement ou à le céder pourra-t-elle le
vendre à un prix de marché qui soit
inférieur au montant des travaux
nécessaires beaucoup de questions par
ailleurs l'article 13 visant à réformer
la procédure d'état de carence lorsqu'un
juge est saisi au fin de nommer un
expert poseli vraiment problème il
institue une présomption de graves
difficultés lorsque des comptes ne sont
pas transmis à l'expert dans un délai de
de mois cela ne semble pas opportun
égard à la gravité des conséquences
d'une telle présomption à savoir
l'expropriation de l'immeuble considéré
sauf à nous en donner la pleine
justification êtes-vous prêt à y
renoncer en fonction de la tenue de nos
débats et des amendements qui seront
adoptés messieurs les rapporteurs nous
arrêterons en responsabilité notre
position de vote sur ce projet de loi
inabouti en l'état alors mes chers
collègues amendons amendons pour
vraiment donner les moyens de remédier à
la Méité à dégrader cela doit nous
rassembler merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Sophie met pour
le groupe démocrate modemme et
[Applaudissements]
indépendant madame le
présid merci
bien monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues je souhaite tout d'abord
remercier le gouvern pour l'arrivée de
ce texte au Parlement il est porteur
d'action concrète sur un sujet si
important pour les Français pour leur
bien-être et pour leur dignité même le
logement partout dans le monde il est au
cœur de la situation sanitaire de
l'accès à l'emploi du défi
environnemental et des fractures tant
territoriales que sociales thématique
omniprésente dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens condition de leur bien-être
le logement est aussi trop peu souvent
source d'inquiétude de frust tion et ce
d'autant plus souvent que le secteur
traverse actuellement une crise grave il
existe des drames bien sûr que nous ne
pouvons pas éluder et qu'il nous
appartient de faire disparaître au plus
vite puisque des centaines de milliers
de personnes ne peuvent pas se loger
comme elle le souhaiteraiit et vivent
dans des conditions
déplorables je suis satisfaite que nous
prenions le problème de l'habitat
dégradé à bras le corp à travers ce
texte et je souhaite que nos débats
permettent de l'enrichir de toutes les
bonnes idées qui seront utiles à nos
concitoyens les jeunes sont frappés par
ces difficultés ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi face à des qualifications
diplômantes de plus en plus importantes
par exemple ils ne parviennent pas à se
loger aussi bien que leurs parents il
est de notre devoir de notre
responsabilité de ne pas laisser
s'installer une confrontation
générationnelle à la conjoncture
économique en France métropolitaine on
estime à 110000 soit 18 % du total le
nombre de copropriétés fragiles le
présent projet de loi entend ainsi
permettre aux acteurs publics comme
copropriétaire d'agir plus rapidement et
plus efficacement pour prévenir la
dégradation des immeubles et éviter de
lourds travaux voire la démolition de
ces derniers des leviers financiers et
administratifs innovants permettront au
copropriétés de dépasser les blocages
rencontrés pour engager des travaux
d'envergure plutôt ils seront entrepris
pour un habitat décent et respectueux
des normes les plus élémentaires
notamment en matière environnementale
moins le coût sera élevé par pour les
propriétaires les locataires ou les
collectivités bref tout le monde y gagne
je souhaiterais saluer également les
mesures adoptées en commission venant
renforcer notre arsenal juridique pour
lutter contre les marchands de sommeil
ou encore accompagner l'hébergement de
personnes délogées à l'occasion
d'opération de lutte contre l'habitat
indigne nous ne pouvons pas laisser
prospérer un commerce opportuniste qui
repose sur le malheur des gens l'article
2 marque une avancée attendue en ouvrant
la possibilité pour toutes les
copropriété de de souscrire à un emprunt
collectif pour le financement de travaux
essentiels et de rénovation énergétique
cette mesure importante s'ajoute à la
subvention ma ma prime renve copropriété
pouvant être accordé au propriétaires
occupants ou bailleurs et les syndicats
de
copropriétaires ce dispositif a déjà été
utilement renforcé et nous devons
continuer de vrai pour inciter nos
concitoyens à effectuer des travaux de
rénovation énergétique le gouvernement
et le Parlement uvre ensemble
aujourd'hui tant pour lutter contre la
précarité énergétique qui touche encore
trop de nos concitoyens que pour
l'émiter les émissions de CO2 d'un
secteur encore trop délaissé lors des
décennies précédentes ce texte est un
premier pas très attendu et nous devrons
continuer à nous pencher sur la
thématique du logement avec la remontée
des taux intérêt et la déconnexion entre
les revenus des ménages et le prix des
logements il faudra agir encore sur la
fiscalité et particulièrement sur celle
des classes moyennes des logements neufs
seront nécessaires ce qui accompagnent
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques puis
d'autres encore nous nous y attellerons
au côté du gouvernement c'est un pas
supplémentaire que nous nous apprêtons à
effectuer si je me montre relativement
optimiste quant à l'issue du vote final
comme vous l'aurez remarqué c'est parce
que je me réjouis de la manière dont les
débats ont progressé jusqu'ici je salue
mon collègue Michael Cosson qui a porté
la voix du groupe des démocrates en
commission des Affaires économique et je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre et
Messieurs les rapporteurs pour ce texte
adopté précédemment à la quasi unanimité
au cours de débat qui se sont bien
déroulés des amendements venus de la
gauche et de la droite ont permis une
coconstruction qui n'est pas aussi rare
que certains se plaisent à le dire et
qui pourrait nous inspirer pour la suite
je formule le vœux que nous puissions
aujourd'hui sur cette lancée et vous
l'aurez compris le groupe démocate
soutiendra ce texte je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur iaki etchanis pour le groupe
socialiste et
apparenté madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président des
affaires économiques messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues comme mes
collègues je ne peux que regretter
l'absence de ministre du Logement de
plein exercice en au vu de la crise que
traverse le logement concernant notre
texte du jour il est rare que des
projets de loi d'autant plus sur
l'habitat et l'urbanisme soient adoptés
à l'unanimité en commission ce vote
traduit en premier lieu un constat
partagé avec tous nos élus locaux
fronter à un parc important d'habitat
dégradé notamment en copropriété le
constat de procédures trop longue trop
complexe ou encore trop tardive et de
conditions de mise en œuvre parfois non
objectivable et insécurisante
juridiquement ce vote tradu en second
lieu la qualité du travail que nous
avons réalisé en commission et je vous
remercie messieurs les les rapporteurs
pour votre ouverture votre esprit de
coconstruction et la précision de vos
argumentaires j'espère que nous
poursuivrons ainsi aujourd'hui notre
groupe a fait adopter 14 amendements et
sous-amendements en commission
permettant de mieux préciser les
dispositifs proposés et d'assurer leur
pleine opérationnalité pardon à cet
égard si nous avions soulevé la
complexité de la première condition
d'éligibilité prévue à l'article 3
nécessitant deux arrêtés l'adoption de
notre amendement remplaçant la nécessité
de prouver la dégradation à terme
irrémédiable de l'immeuble par la seule
poursuite de la dégradation est une
avancée importante elle sécurise
juridiquement la procédure et réduit le
risque du contentieux dès lors la
conservation d'un premier critère
restrictif se justifie et permet de
conserver des garanties légales
suffisantes nous n'y revenons donc pas
en séance nous souhaitons également
poursuivre le renforcement du pouvoir
donné aux juges de scinder ou dissoudre
des ASL ou àul lorsque celles-ci sont
véritablement obstacles à ces objets et
je crois savoir que nous allons pouvoir
avancer sur ce point c'est important
nous proposons également de renforcer
encore la lutte contre les marchands de
sommeil en rendant automatique la
confiscation de l'indemnité
d'expropriation par le juge en cas de
condamnation définitive de l'exproprié
comme marchand de sommeil notre collègue
Stéphane peu a énuméré des exemples
choquants en commission nous pouvons
enfin y mettre fin nous proposerons par
ailleurs de mieux préciser les modalités
de fixation de cette indemnisation afin
que celle-ci ne soit pas décorrélée de
la valeur réelle des biens notamment en
l'absence de référence comparabl dans le
même esprit nous
nous proposerons de préciser les
conditions d'évaluation financière tant
de la démolition que de la remise aux
normes cette dernière ne saurait se
faire autrement qu'au dernier qu'au
dernières normes et non uniquement aux
normes de dessence à cet égard si nous
nous réjouissons du retour de la notion
d'habitabilité à l'article 1er il est
essentiel d'aller au-delà c'est bien
l'amélioration des conditions
d'habitabilité qu'il faut viser
intégrant le confort thermique été hiver
notamment il faut profiter de ces
opérations de travaux lourds pour aller
le plus loin possible dans la
réhabilitation car ces immeubles ne
verront pas de fois de suite l'objet de
tels travaux nous avons saluer en
commission le dispositif de l'article 2
qui doit favoriser la réalisation de
travaux par les copropriétés à l'aide
d'un emprunt collectif je nous alerte
cependant sur le risque de voir des
banques et assureurs ne pas aider celles
de ces copropriétés qui en auraient le
plus besoin alors même qu'elles sont
volontaire l'article 40 ne nous
permettant pas d'apporter cette garantie
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre vous
engagez à ce que l'État apporte ses
garanties à un niveau élevé assez près
ou à minima qu'il existe à la caisse
dépôt ou ailleurs un prêteur et un
assureur en dernier recours il nous faut
monsieur le ministre garantir
l'effectivité de l'accès à cet outil
pour toutes les copropriétés enfin il
nous paraît nécessaire de revenir sur
l'amendement de Monsieur cosos qui a
réduit les conditions de majorité pour
le vote de travaux de rénovation
énergétique si nous soutenons résolument
la réalisation de tels travaux nous
craignons que le vote de travaux aussi
lourd avec une majorité inférieure au
tiers des copropriétaires n un impact
contreproductif au risque de générer des
tensions des impayé et un abandon en
cours d'opération ce qui repousserait
des travaux par ailleurs nécessaires au
calandre grec la sociologie des
copropriétés démontre la nécessité d'un
niveau minima minimal d'adhésion des
copropriétaires pour assurer le succès
de travaux lourds à cet égard l'article
25-1 apporte un équilibre satisfaisant
ainsi mon groupe soutiendra à nouveau ce
texte et tentera de poursuivre avec vous
son amélioration et nous formulons à
nouveau le vœu de voir prochainement un
ministre du Logement de plein exercice
pouvant répondre aux enjeux qui nous
concernent tous et qui sont concernent
surtout nos concitoyens je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Luc lamirot pour le groupe
horizon et
apparenté merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre entre autres du
logement messieurs les rapporteurs
Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues ce projet de loi portant sur
l'accélération et la simplification de
la rénovation de l'habitat dégradé et
des grandes opérations d'aménagement
nous apporte des outils nécessaires pour
réduire les effets de la crise du
logement que nous
traversons cette proposition tire
l'expérience de mi-parcours du plan
initiative propriété lancé en 2018 pour
rappel ce plan accompagne la
requalification de 88000 logements situé
dans les copropriétés en difficultés et
engage près d'un milliard
d'euros ce dispositif a été mis en place
afin de répondre aux problématiques que
rencontrent de nombreuses copropriétés
la mauvaise gestion de ces copropriétés
apporte des dégradations qui peuvent
être irréversible et qui engage notre
sécurité
publique après 5 ans de de mise en œuvre
de nombreux dysfonctionnements ont été
relevés par les acteurs concernés par la
mise en place des procédures pour
relever les copropriétés en difficultés
il est donc nécessaire d'apporter des
solutions pour soutenir le plan
initiative afin de faciliter et
d'accélérer la rénovation des habitats
dégradés le chapitre 1er de ce projet de
loi met en place des mesures qui
permettront une intervention en amont
dans les propriétés dégradées avant que
ces dégradations soient initive
l'article 2 prévoit aussi la possibilité
pour les syndicats de copropriété de
contracter un prêt collectif pour
financer les travaux essentiels et de
rénovation
énergétique cette mesure permettra de
faciliter la réalisation des travaux
essentiels et de rénovation énergétique
permettant l'amélioration du cadre de
vie et de la transition écologique elle
permettra également de réduire les
délais de recherche de financement qui
peuvent parfois s'entendre s'étendre sur
une année cela ralentit considérablement
la rénovation des
copropriétés le second chapitre de ce
projet de loi prévoit des mesures visant
à accélérer les procédures de recyclage
et de transformation des copropriétés et
les opérations d'aménagement
stratégique des dispositions permettront
de sécuriser le cadre juridique des
expropriations qui je le rappelle sont
nécessaires pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et indispensables pour
recycler les habitats urbains l'examen
du projet de loi en commission a conduit
à l'adoption de plusieurs amendements
visant à renforcer la portée du texte en
ce qui concerne la modernisation du
fonctionnement des copropriétés et
l'amélioration de la circulation de
l'information les dispos dispositifs de
lutte contre les marchands de sommeil en
instaurant des sanctions pénales plus
sévère le renforcement du pouvoir de
maire afin d'assurer une meilleure
application des mesures de démolition
des constructions de juget irrégulières
et présentant des risques pour la
sécurité et la santé des
résidents nous avons tous conscience que
le secteur du logement est en tension et
que nous devons agir pour que nos
concitoyens puissent se loger dans des
habitats dignes et abordables c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement de cette
majorité et cette majorité sont
plètement mobilisé avec un ministre qui
a dans son portefeuille le logement donc
je le répète parce que ça ça semblait
pas euh acquis pour beaucoup d'entre
vous pour simplifier les procédures
judiciaires et administratives pour
sécuriser les acteurs impliqués
renforcer les outils permettrant
d'accompagner le plan initiative
copropriété permettant une intervention
en amont et d'éviter les dégradations
définitive soutenir la production de
logement abordable avec l'investissement
de de 4,6 milliards d'euros pour le
dispositif ma prime renove pour toute
cette raison le le groupe horizon et
apparenté votera pour donc pour cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre du Logement merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Julien Baillou pour le groupe
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
nupes je
remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre messieurs
les les rapporteurs comment on fait les
bébés quand on n' pas de
logement comment on fait les bébés quand
on s'inquiète pour le paiement de son
loyer comment on fait les bébé quand on
a un logement mal
isolé je dis ça parce que dans dans ce
qui fait lieu de discours de politique
générale le Président la semaine
dernière a parlé de réarmement
démographique ça ça semblait être sa
priorité il a pas parlé de logement ou à
peine et pourtant le logement c'est la
première des préoccupations des Français
et des Français et C devrait être la
priorité la priorité des priorités de ce
nouveau gouvernement et ça a été dit on
sort à peine d'une vague de froid et non
le gouvernement n'a pas de ministère
dédié au
logement et si Emmanuel Macron son
gouvernement sont pas les seuls
responsables ou les premiers
responsables ils sont néanmoins en
fonction depuis 2017 2014 même pour ce
qui est l'ancien ministre de l'Économie
et donc on peut pas passer à côté d'un
constat unanime partagé par tout le
monde c'est une crise conjoncturelle et
structurelle une bombe sociale et non le
gouvernement ne s'en occupe pas n'en
prend pas la mesure et pire il l'aggrave
c'est la suppression de la garantie
universelle des loyers c'est le
caractère facultatif de l'encadrement
des loyers c'est la fragilisation du
logement social
c'est la loi casbariant qui pénalise les
impayés qui pénalise les plus précaires
qui ouvre même le la brèche à un retour
de la prison pour dette c'est les
meublés touristiques qu'on enencadre pas
suffisamment et quand nous parlementaire
députés sénateur sénatrice nous
parvenons à la faveur d'une maladresse
du gouvernement à supprimer la niche
fiscale Airbnb on nous dit rassurez-vous
c'est une maladresse rassurez-vous c'est
une erreur et non nous n'appliquerons
pas la loi et bien je le dis à
l'hypothétique sur ministre du Logement
si vous n'appliquez pas la loi si vous
n'appliquez pas le projet de loi de
finance qui prévoit de raboter la niche
fiscale vous devrez en répondre non
seulement devant les tribunaux
administratifs mais également au pénal
j'aimerais bien savoir qui est le
ministre de logement qui est le futur
ministre de logement je ne sais pas en
attendant le gouvernement ne prend pas
la mesure de la crise du logement et il
l'aggrave c'est le manque de place le
plus fragrant de manière structurelle et
conjoncturelle le 115 qui répond plus et
les femmes enceintes ou les enfants qui
ne sont même plus prioritaires à Paris
la préfecture nous dit dit en dessous de
7 mois de grossesse les femmes ne sont
plus prioritaires et au-delà de 3 mois
les nourrçons ne sont plus prioritaire
voilà la réalité du 115 en île-de-fance
et je vous le dis c'est un choix
politique pleinement politique d'assumer
d'accepter que des gens dorment à la rue
et ils meurent c'est exactement ce que
disait l'abé piierre à cette même
tribune à la faveur d'une vague de froid
à nouveau il interpellit le gouvernement
qui déjà il accusait d'inaction et
d'insensibilité et il y a trop de
douleur trop de souffrance trop de haine
qui naissent de ces souffrances et à
quelques heures des quelques jours des
encablures quelques encablures pardon
des 70 ans de l'appel du 1er février
1954 le logement est toujours plus
catalyseur d'inégalité dans ce
pays il disait mes amis au secours une
femme est morte ce matin à 3h du matin
sur le trottoir du boulevard Sébastopol
serrant dans la main le papier par
lequel on l'avait expulsé la semaine
dernière plusieurs personnes sont mortes
de froid et on n pas admin du
logement absence de vision globale qui
est manifeste aujourd'hui alors que nous
étudions le texte sur les copropriétés
dégradées c'est issue d'un rapport
présenté par les maires Mathieu etanotin
et Michel lut que je salue et qui
préconisait d'ailleurs des mesures
réglementaires que nous qu'un
gouvernement s'il y avait eu un ministre
du Logement dédié aurait pu prendre sans
attendre l'examen de ce projet de loi
une fois ceci posé lescopropriétés
dégradé c'est fondamental et c'est une
étape bien venue que ce texte pour
prévenir traiter l'habitat
indigne un texte technique avec des
mesures que nous soutiendrons et
peut-être que nous parviendrons à
l'améliorer encore le prè collectif est
une bonne mesure et les écologistes et
d'autres groupes ont également soulevé
la la situation d'insalubrité des locaux
vacants ou devenu vacant qui
finalement le propriétaire n'étant plus
tenu d'exécuter des les mesures
prescrites de rénovation ça pouvait
avoir un effet pervers d'incitation à la
vacance nous y avons remédié en
commission et c'est heureux
mais je j'espère avoir insisté
suffisamment lourdement ce projet de loi
s'inscrit pas dans un ensemble ou un
plan global pour le logement où est la
réflexion sur la précarité énergétique
dans lescopropriétés dégradées où les
difficultés pour les ménages pauvres où
est le plan d'action pour adapter nos
logements aux vagues de froid en hiver
et aux canicules en été le ministre non
pas du logement mais de l'écologie nous
avez parlé d'une France à 4 degrés
comment fait-on quand AXA nous disait il
y a 8 ans une France à 4°grés n'est plus
assurable bref
nous nous attendons une vision de long
terme si vous ne l'avez pas nous vous la
proposons en attendant les solutions
existent si elles ne sont pas mises en
œuvre ça n'est qu'un manque de volonté
politique et une indifférence à la
situation je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Emmanuelle
Ménard en tant que députée non
inscrite
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues le texte qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui est technique et dense il
touche plusieurs codes le code pénal le
code de l'expropriation le code de la
construction et de l'habitation et le
code de l'urbanisme et il vise à
l'accélération et à la simplification de
la rénovation de l'habitat dégradé
mais je vous avoue être extrêmement gêné
de démarrer l'examen de ce projet de loi
alors que nous n'avons pas de ministre
du Logement de plein
exercice depuis 30 ans de nombreuses
lois ont été votées et ont créé de
nouveaux outils parfois mal connus qui
se sont superposés les uns aux autres
rendant de plus en plus complexe il faut
bien l'admettre leur mise en œuvre
résultat des courses et face à des
charges d'investissement importantes les
délais de de réhabilitation des
immeubles sont parfois très longs et
peuvent aller jusqu'à 15 ou 20 ans des
copropriétaires paupérisés qui se
retrouvent peu à peu dans
l'impossibilité de payer leurs charges
ou les travaux d'entretien des immeubles
qui se dégradent et dont la valeur
marchande ne cesse de baisser des
occupants qui sont dans l'impossibilité
financière de se reloger ailleurs tous
les ingrédients sont réunis pour former
un habitat indigne qui touche
aujourd'hui environ un million de
personnes en France et ne nous leurons
pas si les marchands de sommeil ont
intérêt à la dégradation du bâti car
c'est ainsi qu'ils peuvent loger les
plus démunis dans des conditions
intolérables la moitié des logements
insalubr sont occupés par leurs
propriétaires eux-mêmes souvent pauvres
fragiles âgés et démunis devant la
complexité des procédures et des travaux
à entreprendre et l'exigence de mener
des travaux de rénovation notamment
énergétique a encore aggravé leur
situation les situations se dégradent
parfois trop et deviennent
irrattrapables c'est ce que ce projet de
loi souhaite éviter en donnant les
moyens aux collectivités d'agir en amont
de la dégradation définitive d'un
immeuble et en clarifiant les
possibilités de recourir à des
opérations de restauration immobilière
c'est d'ailleurs l'attente des élus
locaux pour lutter contre l'habitat
dégradé de leur commune plusieurs
mesures techniques de ce texte vont dans
le bon sens l'élargissement de la
définition des opérations de
restauration immobilière qui est prévu à
l'article 1er l'article 2 qui prévoit de
faciliter les emprunts collectifs même
s'il soulève quelques questions et
notamment celle de l'accompagnement des
copropriétaires modestes ou encore
l'article 3 qui crée une nouvelle
procédure d'expropriation pour les
immeubles frappés par un arrêté de
police sans être pour autant dans une
situation de dégradation irréédiable
afin d'anticiper justement
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics je
ne peux malheureusement pas passer en
revue toutes les dispositions de ce
texte mais l'une d'entre elle me semble
particulièrement intéressante l'article
8 bis qui prévoit en effet que le
règlement du plan local d'urbanisme
pourra définir des secteurs dans
lesquels est obligatoire pour tout
immeuble bâti la réalisation au moins
une fois tous les 10 ans d'un diagnostic
structurel incluant une description des
désordres observés et évaluant les
risques que ceci présente pour la
sécurité des occupants et celle du
voisinage la mise en place d'un tel
dispositif sera évidemment contraignant
pour les propriétaires mais il devrait
offrir aux collectivités une meilleure
connaissance de l'état structure de
certaines zones bâties dégradées et leur
éviter d'intervenir au coup par coup par
arrêté de péril c'est évidemment un
progrès en revanche je ne vois rien
concernant l'exploitation de ces
diagnostics quit des travaux à engager
en fonction de leurs résultats et qui se
chargera de vérifier que les travaux
sont réellement effectués et bien
effectués de même je ne peux que me
féliciter de l'article 8 ter qui prévoit
que le fait de mettre à la disposition
d'une personne moyennant une
contrepartie un hébergement incompatible
avec la dignité humaine et puni de 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 200000 € d'amende
il est temps de punir de manière très
claire et très ferme les marchands de
sommeil en conclusion je souhaite
rappeler un principe essentiel même s'il
ne plaît pas forcément à nos entreprises
du bâtiment il nous faut accorder la
même importance à la réhabilitation des
logements anciens qu'à la production de
logements neufs n'est pas le cas un
élargissement du prêt à tau zéro dans
l'ancien y compris pour les communes en
zone tendue pourrait y contribuer et il
est plus que temps je vous remercie